this video is proudly sponsored by
Squarespace to many people the idea the
premise of brain training is inherently
highly appealing theoretically by
exercising your brain you could become
witty in conversation you could remember
more details you could become more
charming and charismatic you could solve
problems and come up with amazing ideas
to take your career to the next level
and maybe even Advance mankind this is
why films like Limitless are so popular
and it's something that all of us I
think have some interest in at least but
compared with training the body training
the brain gets a lot less attention and
part of the issue here is the narrative
surrounding brain training because
unfortunately it's not highly positive
see most studies find that brain
training doesn't really train your brain
doesn't really provide that much useful
transfer to the real world many of these
brain training tools that sell
themselves as such they're not backed by
science and what we often find is that
all you're really training yourself in
is that task so by using the brain
training program you might see yourself
get better at doing that program but
that doesn't mean you're necessarily
going to be better at solving problems
in the real world or paying attention
when you're driving but this is where I
take a little bit of umbrage with a lot
of the research and a lot of the
narrative surrounding brain training you
see unlike exercise and physical
training we seem to have this idea that
we should be able to train our brains in
like 10 minutes a day or less and that
all we're going to need is some basic
tools that you can get for free online
if I write you a really basic training
program and I said do this for five
minutes a day and then I studied you in
a few weeks time and found you hadn't
made huge gains then I wouldn't just say
that physical training or weightlifting
doesn't work and yet this is the kind of
approach we see taken to brain training
we know thanks to brain plasticity that
the brain can be changed and we know
that there are many things we can do to
cause functional and structural changes
within the brain I have been training my
brain for the last 15 20 years I've been
doing all sorts of things from
ambidexterity training to meditation to
using tools like dual end back and even
building my own brain training programs
I've been working out in a manner that
is designed to also train my brain so in
all this time and by giving it
significant Focus I guess the question
is have I noticed any difference and has
it impacted my life in any big
meaningful way and whilst it hasn't
necessarily gone exactly according to
plan or as I expected I can definitely
say that yes training my brain has
brought about some huge changes to my
lifestyle the way I approach problems
the way I perform and I don't think I
would be here sitting and talking to you
right now if it hadn't been for some of
the brain training practices that I've
been engaging in so yes brain training
in my experience at least can be highly
effective so I'm going to tell you my
story I'm going to tell you the tools
and the methods I've used and then you
can take from that what you will oh and
we're also going to have a guest
appearance from a friend of mine Janet
rajapaxi who goes all the way back to
University we live together in Halls and
whereas I've done a lot of brain
training he's done a lot of meditation
and I have been able to see the impact
that's had on him and how it's affected
him he's gone quite deep with it at
times he even went on a Meditation
Retreat a silent Retreat so yeah I'll
tell you how brain training has affected
me and a bit about how meditation has
affected me but he's also gonna have
some really interesting insights there
because yeah he's someone who I think
has really benefited from meditation and
he's a great example of what it can help
you achieve you can do shots in your
face as well yes
so I guess it all began when I started
doing my a levels and I decided to take
psychology and then I took this one step
further when I went to University and
decided to make psychology my
undergraduate degree so I was already
really interested in physical
performance I told people I wanted to be
a stunt man what I really wanted to be
was a superhero I worked out I'd won
team bodybuilder of the month on
bodybuilding.com and I was doing martial
arts and all sorts of other things but I
knew that I really wanted to train my
brain as well as my body and that's why
I took psychology so I could learn how
to tap into the potential of the brain
you know just a normal way to choose
your career options perhaps it shouldn't
come as a huge surprise but what I
learned when I started Psychology was
that most of the curriculum was not
geared towards becoming Batman who'd
have thought but there were some things
I learned that I was then able to
extrapolate and build from they served
as great launching off points where I
could then do my own research and get
some results one of the first things
that I started using and had real impact
on my lifestyle was something called CBT
cognitive behavioral therapy this isn't
a form of brain training rather it's a
psychotherapeutic tool that's used in
Clinical Psychology to treat a range of
conditions ranging from phobias to
depression to whatever else it teaches a
form of metacognition that is thinking
about thinking it teaches you how to
observe your own thoughts and negative
thought patterns in particular and then
challenge them using cognitive
restructuring tools like thought
challenging and hypothesis testing and
then to replace those negative thoughts
with positive ones I won't go into it in
huge detail now because I have made a
video on this now this has actually
proved instrumental for me ever since
then I've used CBT many times to address
issues with my own thought and to even
improve my performance by changing what
I'm focusing on and how it's affecting
me for example it can be very effective
at improving your adherence to training
programs and diets but right away I
actually used it to treat a kind of
phobia ahead of peeing in public urinals
at least do you find it awkward being in
public urinals not because I was shy of
you know what was down there but because
I thought that if I couldn't urinate in
the public urinals people would think I
was just hanging out in there and I was
a weirdo so I'd get all worked up and
that'll prevent me from being able to
urinate but then I use CBT techniques in
order to teach myself to get over this
and once I learned CBT I did I treated
this phobia of my own in less than a
week so yeah CBT was extremely
beneficial for me and it has been going
forwards and just the mindfulness that
comes with that of knowing your own
thoughts recognizing them thinking how
are these affecting me and how could
this be better but this was just
scratching the surface of what you can
do with brain training and some of the
alternative techniques you can use to
enhance your cognitive performance what
I'd learned about next was really far
more profound so what I learned about
next psychology that I found very
interesting was actually two things that
go nicely hand in hand firstly I learned
about brain plasticity neuroplasticity
the way the brain can reform itself
build new neurons and new connections
but this was very interesting to me of
course and so was the corpus callosum
the bundle of neurons that cross between
the two hemispheres and connect the left
and right sides of your brain this was
really interesting because of course it
needs to convey a huge amount of
information from the left side of the
brain to the right side of the brain and
this of course contributes hugely to
Global connectivity the things like
creativity Etc and unexpectedly we know
that Einstein had a much thicker corpus
callosum which some people have
postulated might have helped to explain
his ability to visualize these Concepts
and then understand them in terms of
mathematics by combining different brain
areas and using them together so to me
thickening the corpus callosum via brain
plasticity was a no-brainer no pun
intended and so the logical next step
for me was to train ambidexterity so for
a long time I was writing with my left
hand practicing other things with my
left hand and this has brought mixed
results today I do have slightly better
left-handed writing than most people not
that that has a huge benefit on my
lifestyle and I'm already a very
creative person and I'm good at creative
problem solving I don't know whether the
ambidexterity training has enhanced that
at all I would say possibly maybe a
little bit
but yeah I didn't stick with it as
religiously over a huge amount of time
as I would have liked or something I've
done in fits and spurts and I can't say
I've drastically noticed any huge
changes so yeah I would say the
ambidextility training is certainly
something interesting to experiment with
but it wasn't one that had a massive
impact on my lifestyle and there is also
the issue of transferability again here
because after all there are plenty of
activities that involve both hands and
dexterity in the non-dominant hands such
as playing a guitar and we don't
suddenly see that everyone who plays a
guitar is extremely creative and you
know coming up with the next theory of
relativity it's something that I'm
continuing to research and experiment
with definitely worth trying not
necessarily groundbreaking
and it was also about this time that I
learned about what's definitely the Big
Kahuna when it comes to brain training
and cognitive performance that being
working memory the way we learned about
this in Psychology both in sick form and
at University was as this store for your
memory your most short-term memory that
worked kind of like RAM does on a
computer so use it to store information
that you're manipulating and working
with the obvious example being if
someone tells your phone number and you
go to write it down use your working
memory to store that number whilst you
go to get to pen you also use working
memory to store numbers that you're
carrying over when you're performing a
long multiplication in your head for
example you can increase this capacity
through training it seems According to
some of the studies from a minimum of
about five to a maximum of about nine
and by doing this of course it could
potentially increase your computational
abilities now I was actually quite down
on this originally I thought in what way
and again this is talking practically
about brain training in what way is
remembering a couple of numbers going to
drastically impact lifestyle like
there's a calculator for most
calculations and how often do I really
need to write down a phone number it's
just not something I thought would have
a big impact on my life not that I
wasn't a little bit interested but I
couldn't have been more wrong about this
what I would ultimately find is that
working memory could be the key to
unlocking absolutely huge gains in terms
of cognitive performance and where we
see this most I think is in visual
attention and sports Vision so
essentially when you're looking around
the world around you you have a narrow
Focus you can only pay attention to one
or two things at a time and then you
have to stitch these together in your
brain to create an idea of where you are
to create a cohesive vision of what's
around you so most of what you're seeing
isn't really out there it's actually in
your head it's the construct that you've
created based on not only what you're
seeing the snapshots that you've darted
your eyes around to quickly gather as
much information as possible but also
based on things like schemas and ideas
of what things look like memories and
assumptions and you use these to this
kind of Patchwork idea of what's going
on and that's what you use to navigate
and the same goes for sounds and even
your body parts in space you can only
focus on so much so you have to stitch
together this fabricated reality that we
live in and this is powered by your
working memory you use your working
memory to hold that information to glue
it together and to understand what's
around you so the greater your working
memory the more accurate information can
bring in from the world around you and
used to stitch together in order to come
up with a more cohesive and accurate
picture this can actually increase your
vision that's why it's called visual
attention if you can see more things and
store that information then you're
actually more aware than someone who can
see things but immediately forgets them
or replaces them with you know made-up
information so what we actually see is
that by training and enhancing your
working memory you can increase your
whole experience of the world around you
your subjective experience can become
higher resolution you can gain more
insight and this will also even bleed
everyone into things like creativity and
memory you're alertness in a
conversation because you can track what
people are saying more you can store the
information in your head more easily
think about what you're going to say
next this is huge it can change
everything just boosting your working
memory in this more real world way so
one of the biggest ways that we train
working memories with something called
Jill and back training that's just a
test that requires you to store the
position and value of different numbers
and then add to them over time the
amount that you're storing in your brain
and what we've seen though is that the
transfer from this to real world
activities is really quite limited there
are mixed studies some suggesting that
it can be useful some suggesting that it
can't some suggesting that we need to be
able to get to really really high levels
before we see transfer to real world
activities but the issue here again is
specificity and if you're interested in
functional training if you watch this
Channel at all then you'll know what
specificity is it means choosing an
exercise that perfectly matches what it
is you're going to do so if you want to
jump higher then box jumps are perfect
because they're highly specified to that
activity you're emulating the activity
you want to utilize you're jumping so if
we want to train our working memory in a
way that's going to enhance our ability
to move through the world then just
storing numbers in our head isn't really
going to necessarily do that in the most
optimal way we want to train our working
memory in a multimodal multi-sensory
manner in order to train those specific
skills who can then transfer to sports
Etc
fortunately there are tools we can use
to do this as I discovered with my
research and I was even lucky enough to
try out something that was exclusively
normally available to high-level
athletes a military personnel
these are basically tasks that challenge
you to follow objects as they move
around a screen in three dimensions and
to retain that information where they
are and predict where they're going to
be Etc this of course is training a
working memory the ability to store that
information and divide your attention
but at the same time it's doing it in
that multi-sensory visual Manner and you
can take this to the next level by using
it in virtual reality where you actually
submerging that 3D world and you can
train your brain in a far more exciting
and visceral manner I came across a
brain training tool like this called
react and this is available on the
Oculus store I tried it out really early
on when I saw it because I knew it was
exactly up my street from the research
I'd done and I started training with it
on a fairly regular basis I also wrote a
review of it on my website and this led
to the developers getting in touch with
me and saying that they'd like to invite
me to use their far more premium option
and that was newer trainer and it had a
similar premise it would fire objects at
you and you'd have to react to which
kind of object they were remember where
they were in space and back them back
towards specific places and I found this
really useful I'd change with it for a
while very excited to be using something
that you know normally wouldn't be
accessible to the public and to give it
a proper shot so I trained with it for
several months and obviously as well
this had the benefit of being a lot more
fun than dual end back because it's
essentially like playing a computer game
that said I also did find that it was
somewhat Limited in scope because it was
designed for arthrace and for military
personnel which again isn't what I do
for a living so it didn't have a massive
transfer to me you know it's not going
to impact on my writing or my
presentation skills or even really my
training to a huge degree I didn't
notice it improved my verbal fluency for
example and I didn't get to the point if
I'm honest where I noticed objects
moving in slower motion which is one of
the premises one of the things that they
claimed could eventually happen if you
trained with it long enough certainly
didn't transfer to then better scores on
the Dual end back test which would have
been really interesting if it had so I
actually decided to make my own brain
training program to Target working
memory called bio mind and you can
download that for free from the website
it's pay what you like you will have to
put in your details because I couldn't
find a way to get that to work without
asking for details but basically you put
in your information and you can choose
to pay whatever you want including
nothing and you'll get a link to
download biomind here you're flying
through a 3D space a pseudo 3D space and
you have to count the number of objects
you see and react once you see a certain
number of objects however the challenges
that you have to react to different
numbers of different types of object and
then I'm even going to introduce sounds
and things so you're working across
different modalities this is more memory
based than the more Sports Vision
focused neurotrainer and other 3D
tracking tools like it it's supposed to
be kind of halfway house between the two
and something fun that you can do
wherever on the phone because that's the
other issue with you know virtual
reality brain training you need space
and you need time you can't really just
do it on the toilet and as you guys know
I like my incidental training I trained
with my mind and found it fairly
effective I was improving but then if
I'm honest I have fallen off the wagon
with that one and the reason being that
I've switched to iOS and I'm learning to
Port it to iOS but at the moment it's
only available on Android or PC or I'm
also about to offer it on Mac it wasn't
as beneficial as what I'm about to
discuss which was the biggest Game
Changer in terms of my working memory
but we'll get to that in a moment
because first I want to talk about one
of the underlying principles of working
memory that being Focus if you can train
your focus sufficiently then you can
immediately massively upgrade your
working memory and many other aspects of
your performance this is the underlying
trait if we were to use my at NSP
hierarchy system that powers so many
other brain functions if we think that
working memory is a truly potent
aspect of cognitive performance then
perhaps focus is the true underlying
trait the true Global trait that powers
everything
so there are some theories as to how
working memory works and again I've made
a whole video on this delving into the
kind of underlying mechanics of working
memory in more detail however one of the
biggest theories and something that
makes a lot of sense to me is the notion
that working memory is effectively
tantamount to focus in other words your
ability to store information in your
brain and to keep it there is powered by
your ability to focus on that
information as long as you're focusing
on that qualia on that you know subject
that idea that number whatever it is you
can keep it active in your brain and not
forget it you can then manipulate it if
your focus is divided if it's getting
around you will forget that information
and you won't be able to manipulate it
in the same way so by training Focus we
can theoretically not only focus on our
work better and get all the benefits
that come from Focus but actually
increase our cognitive processing skill
by being able to manipulate more
information at once so perhaps this is
what we should really be focusing on no
pun intended if you want to boost our
working memory so how do we focus on
Focus well the most powerful method is
through meditation through meditation we
can train our brain to focus to quiet
itself to do essentially what we want it
to do so so far I've been making some
sweeping statements perhaps in this
video I'm telling you that working
memory is focused and I'm telling you
that meditation is essentially
boils down to focus as well and these
might seem like left field ideas but if
you watch again I've got a video on
meditation if you watch these videos you
can see how I've reached this point in
my thinking but suffice to say that when
you're quieting your mind what you're
actually doing is just focusing it so
that it doesn't drift and wonder and you
don't have these distracting thoughts
instead what you're doing is you're
focusing on one point whether it's your
breath whether it's a point in space a
visualization or there it's nothing at
all it's essentially your ability to
direct your attention wherever you want
and to avoid distractions and by using
meditation we can do this in an
extremely powerful way
and some anecdotal reports I've read
talk about things like tasting wine with
more richness and detail and seeing
individual raindrops as they walk and
seeing the particles of smoke that they
never noticed before unfortunately I
haven't had the best of experiences with
meditation I use meditation and body
scan meditation in particular as a way
to relax I use it prior to workout
sometimes to increase my man muscle
connection and I talk about that in this
super functional training program both
types and I've attempted to use it you
know in this manner over and over but I
haven't really had huge amounts of
success with it and again there's issues
with adherence here but also even when I
have been strict with it I haven't
noticed huge benefits if I'm completely
honest it's always led to me seeing
people talking about how meditation
changed their life and if I'm honest
being a little bit skeptical like I mean
are you really all that different than
before you started this is why I wanted
to bring my friend Yannick on the show
because I've known him for an extremely
long time he's one of my best friends we
went to University together we lived
together you know I've known pretty darn
well and in the time that I've known him
I've seen a change in him and I think
meditation was a big part of that he is
interested in self-development and
self-improvement just like I am but I
think that the meditation had a big
impact and in particular when he went
away on his Meditation Retreat his
silent retreat I do think he came back
and seemed calmer and I guess that comes
from Focus the ability to block out
distractions or even anxious thoughts
and this is what he described as well so
yeah I I thought that was interesting
because he's someone who I've seen
tangible benefits from the meditation
he's uh you know he's an advert for it
so I thought I'd bring him on and ask
him some questions and here he is
well I found that meditation has given
me sort of a breathing space in the
world
um and allowed me to
to sort of see things more clearly I
feel
stress
as less of an impact on me we've known
each other for a long time I would say
that I've noticed that in you which is a
unique position because you hear and see
so many people advocating for meditation
but then you're like you're just the
normal dude like what what what's so
good about it you know it's not like
Fitness we can see someone's buttload of
muscle however however with you I would
say it's not necessarily something I can
easily verbalize but you do seem more
confident
Etc and Karma I would say I can I can
acknowledge that having
um seeing how long would you say it took
for those sorts of benefits to
materialize
it's it's
interesting I think you certainly notice
the benefits internally for the rest of
the world might see it
um it you can pretty much from one
session
you can actually start feeling better
off the back of it but just like weight
training or exercise it takes a while
and consistency
the benefits to come through and
certainly to start feeling them on a
more everyday level yeah
um
for me personally I'd say it took me
about
six weeks of sort of consistent daily
attempts of meditation and I use the
word attempts because I know it's not
easy and I was a I was the kind of
person that would sit down
and be distracted within three four
seconds my mind was just shooting all
over the place and thoughts were going
everywhere but if you just keep coming
back to it
um you start realizing how much more
easily you can settle into it and
it brought
greater focus in my life I'm able to
focus on things a bit better with
without tuning into the distractions
around me
uh it's left me feeling a lot calmer as
a result and certainly meditation comes
in so many different forms or so many
ways you can attempt it
um it's not just about focusing on the
breath you can do things like gratitude
meditation you can do things like body
scans and all these things bring a form
of Greater awareness
and fundamentally we can have sort of a
greater awareness of ourselves
that we can probably operate better in
the world
would you say there's been any benefits
in terms of maybe your memory or your
working memory
um your ability to be creative or to
juggle information because there are
some definite parallels between those
things and be interesting to know
someone who has experienced success or
you've seen that transfer
I'd definitely say
there has been an improvement in those
areas
um I bring it back to the idea of focus
which then probably is a byproduct means
I'm unable to to remember things better
um but I think if you're able to
work without distraction
and a lot of other areas and sort of
come through and start improving as well
you can delve deeper into when you talk
about creativity in particular
I think having this ability to quiet on
the mind and then see what comes up
as if all my creative sort of outputs
much much more and
as an actor as well that helps now if
you found that interesting I do have a
much longer version of that interview
that discussion over on the patreon page
if you're one of the Brain Trust tier
members you'll get access to that so
yeah check it out there if you like but
something else interesting that came up
um in our discussion and something I've
talked about in the past is the
difference between focused meditation
and non-directive meditation so
non-directive meditation incorporates
some of the Lesser known forms of
meditation where the idea is not to
focus on your breathing or to try and
quiet your mind but rather to allow it
to wonder and to just practice kind of
thinking and this is something that I
have had experience with and that I Am
Naturally inclined to do and I have
developed my own form of this called big
idea meditation where what I will do is
I'll set myself a brain Challenge and
then sit there and just Muse on it for 5
10 20 minutes or do it on a walk I do
this with issues that I'm facing or
problems I want to solve or looking for
Creative Solutions I come up with video
ideas I come with book ideas app ideas
at the same time they also sometimes
just reflect on like the nature of the
universe I have thought deeply on you
know my own Theory of Everything and big
questions like you know what is the
uncertainty principle how could we
describe this mechanistically if you're
interested I might share some of these
thoughts
um they are a bit crazy of course am I
not necessarily what I believe it's just
an interesting logic puzzle and I love
thinking deeply about things like this
but yeah and then at the other end of
the spectrum I'll think about far more
mundane things like I often like to
think about what I would do if I was
writing the next issue of Iron Man it
involves him having a drone which I
think you know they should have done and
instead of being inside his bones he'd
carry his armor as a rucksack I think
that makes a whole load of sense would
be really cool
in other words just a practicing
thinking it's like I said call this big
idea meditation and I've been doing it
in a structured and you know regular
manner now for years years and years and
I actually think that this has had the
biggest and most direct impact on my
life because it's led to some massive
breakthroughs it's I think as you
practice this creative problem solving
and this daydreaming and this thinking
you become better at doing it and so as
a result I've come up with all kinds of
ideas I've taught myself to program much
of which was just done in my own head
from there I've built apps my big hit
was multi-screen multitasking you know
back in the day when you couldn't use
split screen on an Android device I had
the idea of having one app that
contained Windows within it and each
window was essentially mini app so you'd
be able to manipulate them just as you
would do on a Windows desktop and then
you'd be able to browse the web and
write documents even browse your files
and the way it got around the limit of
not being able to multitask was the fact
that this was actually one app with
multiple apps within it then you just
had the ability to manipulate them this
was before any of these other similar
apps existed on the market mine was the
first one and it took off in a big way
sold over 10 000 copies in the first
year and for a time being changed my
life you know I became an app developer
and it was huge and I remember just the
excitement of seeing those sales numbers
go up I was at a party it was incredible
and I was just so amazed that all this
had come from just an idea I'd learned
to program come up with this idea and
release it on the store once I built it
and there's so many small challenges
within that but all of them I solved
just in my head you know just big idea
thinking from there it led to writing
books on programming working for Android
authority and becoming a tech journalist
so yeah it's been huge for me this big
idea of thinking and this channel is
powered by it I'm not sure if you deep
in meditation but it certainly could be
classed as a form of meditation but
sometimes I would do things like free
writing and that's as simple as sitting
down with a black you know black piece
of paper and a pen and just write it and
seeing what comes up that to me could be
a form of meditation I've done things
like walking meditations that's as
simple as if you're out in nature in
particular
ly which sort of just
being very focused more intentional at
each step or observe them around you you
don't have to be focusing on your breath
or your body sometimes you can put the
focus outside as well but sort of being
intentional with it is the most
important thing
so one of the reasons that I think I've
struggled with things like dual end back
training and traditional forms of
meditation is that I do think I have a
significant cognitive deficit when it
comes to working memory and elements of
focus I think I have got ADHD or
inattentive add at least now I know this
is a very trendy diagnosis at the moment
and everybody is saying that they've got
add and that's understandably garnered
some skepticism however I do think that
I might be a genuine case here for
example I can't lay my table in the
morning without setting at least one
thing in the wrong place probably
multiple like every morning I'll give my
wife like the kid bowl of cereal or I'll
give my one-year-old son a cup of coffee
and just put everything in the wrong
place and I mean that's weird I mean I
do it every single morning and I make
the same mistakes regularly you know
I'll go around the wrong side of the car
I turn on the TV I normally sit there
staring at it for a minute before I work
out which app I need or where to go
I'm acting
so they see the chest table because
they'll be like what did you just say
move
safely leave another Point as she goes
all the way back to my childhood where I
was in the you know learning assisted
classes for time because I was so
disorganized you know I did well
academically but I was known as this
kind of absent-minded kid who forgot all
this stuff and yeah I think I probably
have some form of ADD and I'm seeking a
diagnosis now that's largely held me
back and I think in many ways it's been
advantageous but what I've been doing by
doing big idea meditation and steering
away from you know focused meditation is
you know training what I'm already good
at is like going to the gym and I've got
you know strong pecs for example whereas
I don't have very strong glutes doing
nothing but bench press That's
essentially what I've been doing I've
been enhancing and enhancing the thing
that I'm good at which is creative
problem solving creative thinking deep
thinking and not really doing what I
should be doing which is training my
focus my ability to be witty and present
I can be witty in conversation once I
get deep into it but if someone speaks
to me in this Street and I'm not
expecting it takes me a good minute to
think of a response by which time
they've usually left so yeah this has
been the sticking point so I think what
I really need to do is combine the
non-directed forms of meditation with
something more traditional like
transcendental or CBT and then I'll get
the best of both worlds and in my
discussion with Yannick I was actually a
little bit recorded off camera which is
annoying but he said how he goes for
nature walks and things which I also
highly recommend for Creative problem
solving but he thinks that his practice
in more focused forms and meditation
allow him to then get more from the
creative and non-directed reputation
because he has that ability to focus and
to manipulate that information so I
think just as in Fitness it's not good
enough to say you know lift weight in my
opinion you should be lifting weights
and doing cardio and doing mobility and
I think it's the same with brain
training it's not enough just to train
Focus you need to train creativity but
you can't also just focus on the
creativity so I need to do more for my
focus and I need to really double down
on the Dual end back Stuff Etc I've made
myself another app which is designed to
train focus in the same way that
meditation does but in a manner that
someone like me can cope with better so
what it essentially does is shows you a
timer on the screen it counts up in
seconds and every now and then it misses
a second so you have to stay focused and
you have to hit space or tap the screen
when that happens I'm going to make that
available to you guys on patreon in the
lowest tier one dollar you can always
just sign up and then cancel again at
the end of the month so it's one dollar
but much appreciated if you want to try
it out but there are other ways you
could do something similar
but I did also say that there was
another area that I'd been using that
had improved my working memory to a huge
degree more so than any of these other
things so I think it's time that I talk
about that and it's actually a bit of a
surprise to me as well
so the thing that's made the biggest
impact to my working memory whether or
not I've got ADHD it has addressed some
of those you know scattered brain
qualities and my family my wife has said
they've seen an improvement in me in the
time since I've been doing this more
is movement training and skills training
and this is quite surprising to me
because I know on paper that skills
training is good for working memory I
talked about this in my book functional
training and Beyond and adaptive
training and in super functional
training one and two the studies are
there and if you extrapolate them you
can see that it has a big impact things
like balancing on beams balancing and
trees handstands martial arts all of
them can boost our working memory and
the reason for this is partly because it
utilizes the cerebellum which is also
used in other important tasks but it's
also because you actually do need to
focus on multiple things at once in
order to perform these skills so for
example when I'm hand balancing I need
to focus on the sensation of balance I
need to feel the balance and find the
balance and hold it which involves
Contracting and tensing lots of tiny
muscles but at the same time I need to
be focused on my technique I need to
think about maintaining my balance over
the right part of my hands spreading my
fingers having the right distance I need
to contract the groups and keep my core
straight all these things at once or I'm
not going to be able to do a handstand
properly keeping my legs together not
letting them just flail around at the
top there and this requires working
memory and so it also trains working
memory in a way that I do find fun and
engaging and doing martial arts when I'm
throwing a punch I need to think about
relaxing the body retracting the hand is
putting is I throw it out keeping my
guard up rotating at the hip pushing off
the foot etc etc etc
this is working memory in action and
there are studies that show that a
greater working memory enhances skill
acquisition for things like throwing
hoops and again I knew this on paper I
knew that this connection existed and I
believed in it but I didn't think I'd
feel it because like I say I know that
dual end back training can improve your
working memory I know that meditation
can improve your working memory but none
of them were effective for me I didn't
feel them in the everyday you know maybe
there was some benefit there but it
wasn't huge but this has been huge and I
have been training skills as well but
lately I've been focusing on it much
more I've been really focusing on the
calisthenics skills as you guys know
I've been doing more of the martial arts
again and focusing on my technique in
particular and it's also just the way
I've changed how I'm thinking about it I
am thinking more about the technique and
the form you might not see it but I'm
working on it and that's had tangible
benefits on my working memory on my
focus on my ability to manipulate
information hopefully this continues and
I'm going to up it but it's great news
for me because it means that the thing
that I enjoy doing the thing I was doing
anyways is also benefiting my brain more
so than many of the you know more Focus
just more specifically brain training
related things and the really exciting
thing is that this is even actually
transferred to improvements in my dual
and back performance and my biomine
performance oh one other thing worth
mentioning is that what for me solved
the issue of lethargy which I think is
an issue a lot of us have many of us
feel sluggish and brain foggy a lot of
the time unfortunately I found an actual
solution to this it was the training
throughout the day the modular training
the incidental training being constantly
active with multiple micro workouts this
severely energized my brain and since
I've been doing this even if I'm tired I
don't feel sluggish I never feel I've
got brain fog it's actually been pretty
transformative for me and yeah tiredness
as far as it affects cognitive
performance simply isn't an issue since
I've been doing this
so I've been visiting WF house here in
Leicester and I'm recording the
audiobook version of my most recent
print book adaptive training this is a
long full day session of speaking and
trying to have good verbal fluency not
stumble over my words I have to read
ahead and get my mouth around the words
and I'm exhausted and I've got a
headache and it reminds me that things
like this are also brain training and
the same goes for whatever you do for a
living someone who did this for a living
read this amount of words every single
day would have fantastic verbal fluency
and this would be a form of brain
training for me I write a lot and I used
to write a huge amount and I program and
this has had a massive impact on the way
I think and the way I use my brain so
you can do brain training and that can
involve 10 minutes a day of dual end
back or whatever but what you do for
your living and your Main Hobbies and
habits they're going to have a much
bigger impact on changing your brain for
example this is why a lot of people are
now concerned about the amount of time
we spend Doom scrolling or on Tick Tock
because they think we're melting our own
attention spans by getting so used to
getting these short bursts of
information for me something that's had
a huge impact on the way I think is my
writing writing books yeah and writing
for this channel but prior to this I was
a copywriter a freelance copywriter and
I got paid by the word so the more words
I could write in a shorter amount of
time the more I could get paid for doing
so so the incentive was there to write
huge amounts of volume and I would do
this whilst charging a small amount of
money and that's how I beat the
competition so I'd write 10 000 words a
day sometimes 20 000 my record ever was
35 000 words a day and I did this for
years years and years writing this much
every single day as a result I think
it's transformed the way I think I think
it's really helped me to manipulate
ideas and to think deeply on a topic to
think critically all things I was
already somewhat prone to doing these
were all the kind of natural advantages
I had but then I really doubled down on
them by practicing like this and I think
it's one of the reasons that now I can
work so quickly undoubtedly neuropathy
has meant that this has caused physical
changes to my brain and the way I think
I've talked in the past about studies
that show how different careers and
different activities can alter the brain
areas we use when solving problems how
certain athletes like wrestlers usually
more kinesthetic areas of their brain to
solve 3D rotation problems for example
as compared with others that might use
their visual spatial brain areas this is
also worsened in some ways my sort of
scatterbrained absent-minded Professor
Persona because I just get locked onto
these ideas and I can't switch away from
them so how much of this is genetics
versus unintentional brain training I
don't know because now I'm able to work
really quickly to churn out videos write
books and articles and make apps in a
very short amount of time compared to
the competition
likewise programming I think has been
instrumental for me because programming
teaches you how to think using a set of
tools using a framework and this can
actually encourage more creativity and
problem solving because you have to use
the tools available to you I do most of
my programming just as I do most of my
writing in my head and then sit down and
execute on that
clearly what I have done for a living
and what others have done for a living
has profoundly changed our brains and so
this shows us that training and
interventions are capable of changing
the way we think and this has potential
to be profoundly impactful because brain
training could help us to avoid
accidents on the road and to focus more
on our job very important for someone
like a surgeon and perhaps it could help
us to think better and to come up with
better Solutions brain training I still
think has potential to be absolutely
massive and I think I've felt some of
the implications of this myself
so to conclude then what's actually
worked for me for brain training what do
I recommend to you guys what results
should you see
well as we discussed at the beginning
CBT was big for me metacognition
learning to think about thinking has
been huge on top of that ambidexterity
meditation dual impact training all
might have had a small effect but it was
just that it was a small effect big idea
meditation on the other hand has been
instrumental to me and it's something
that I don't hear a lot of other people
doing make deep thinking a focus of your
day set aside time for deep thinking if
you have a problem or an issue focus on
that but alternatively just think about
what you think created the universe
killed the dinosaurs how you'd write the
next James Bond movie whatever it is
practice your creativity practice your
deep thinking because that is what will
lead to breakthroughs in your life you
know being a bit more focused is
important and useful and like I say it
could save your life but if you want to
make big progress in your life then it's
the deep thinking it's the big Ideas
it's the breakthroughs and Paradigm
shifts that can really accomplish that
this is what can change things so
practice big idea meditation I highly
recommend it but combine this with some
form of focus meditation so you don't
end up like me and actually exacer
debate your absent-mindedness that to me
is why I need to do this and in terms of
working memory the thing that had the
biggest impact on me was movement
training and skills training and that
was huge so I highly recommend that
anyways but this is just an extra reason
to do that
now there is another side of the story
and that's the use of neurotropics these
are supplements and pills that are
designed to enhance brain function and
as many of you know I have experimented
with them quite significantly
extensively in the past and some have
been effective I know on paper that
things like creating can be beneficial
but more so for me things like
phosphatidylserine have helped me to
cope with things like burnout however
I'm not going to go into that into a lot
of detail here and the reason for that
is that there have been some nootropics
that I've utilized that have had a
profound impact on my brain function for
Better or For Worse I don't want to talk
about them here because hey YouTube
doesn't love talking about neurotropics
B this video is definitely long enough
already and see whatever I say if it
sounds interesting I know I'm going to
encourage some people to try it and I
don't necessarily want to do that my
ethos for this channel has always been
that I won't ever recommend anything to
you that I wouldn't recommend to my
daughter or my sister and so that goes
for nootropics I do not recommend them
the negatives outweigh the positives and
whilst they improve your cognitive
functioning some areas it always comes
with a drawback it always comes with a
price however it is interesting and if
you want to hear me talk about my
experiences with them then head over to
the patreon again and you'll see the
longer uncut version of this and you can
watch that
that's available to everyone in the
second and third tier so if you head
over there now you'll get the focus app
you'll get the full discussion with
Yannick and you'll get the extra bit the
after dark director's cut of this video
which also comes without adverts and it
always arrives early so check that out a
huge thank you to my patrons who are
there already
the Brain Trust here also has access to
an exclusive Discord server I hugely
appreciate the support it's allowed me
to buy the second camera so I now have
two angles to film but to everyone who
watched this a gigantic thank you
whatever the case I massively appreciate
it especially if you made it all the way
through to the end this is a long one
I'd love to know your experiences with
brain training down below is it
something you're interested in what's
been useful for you and what would you
like me to focus a video on in future in
that regard let me know thanks a ton for
watching this one guys I'll see you next
time
bye for now
as I say though developing your brain on
its own isn't going to hugely change
your life it's what you do with that new
brain function and a fantastic creative
project to Endeavor on is of course
building your own website not only is it
a great creative exercise it can also
genuinely change your life it has
changed mine Squarespace is a website
building platform and the one I would
recommend most people to use the reason
being that Squarespace is extremely
simple and easy to get started with you
can build a website in minutes and with
zero coding knowledge but at the same
time it's powerful enough that you can
build whatever you want you could build
a full business from here in fact many
of the biggest brands on the web are
powered by Squarespace that's because
Squarespace gives you all the tools you
could possibly need they allow you to
create blog posts with beautiful
formatting schedule posts for later and
more you can share that content to
social media easily thanks to social
media tools or have your social media
feed appear directly on your home page
you can build a community directly on
your website thanks to a commenting
system that supports threaded comments
replies and likes or generate Revenue
with members only gated content you can
also view Analytics and see where your
visitors are coming from learn about
them so that you can better Target them
with your business strategy and of
course if you want to take the revenue
generation to the next level then there
are inbuilt and Powerful e-commerce
tools to allow you to sell products or
digital products directly from your
website you can expand all these
features with a whole host of plugins
too for example if you want to enhance
the e-commerce features then you can do
things like tax reconciliation global
Shipping and much more as I say
Squarespace is extremely easy to get
started with but offers all of the tools
all of the potential to build a huge
business if that's what you want to do
head over to squarespace.com to learn
more and when you're ready to go visit
squarespace.com forward slash bioneer
and you'll get 10 off of your first
domain or website link in the
description down below thanks again to
Squarespace for sponsoring this video
thanks to you guys for watching till the
end
and bye for now